we are learning new details about the 13
u.s troops killed in last week's terror
attack in kabul they include an
expectant father his baby was due in
three weeks a devoted son and a beloved
sister president biden watched yesterday
as the remains of the american service
members arrived back in the u.s during
an emotional homecoming at dover air air
force base in delaware wii xi jiang is
at the white house with more on the
story good morning i watched that
ceremony it's very difficult to watch
the caskets come off the plane and now
you're hearing the stories about who
these people were it's tough
good morning gail good morning everybody
it sure is and what's especially
striking is when you see their ages only
one of them was over the age of 30.
president biden said the bravery of
these service men and women helped move
more than 117 000 people out of harm's
way and into safety he and the first
lady met privately with the families of
the fallen before watching over their
return to u.s soil
on sunday they came home
11 men and two women who died serving
their country president biden and first
lady jill biden attended their dignified
transfer in dover delaware
the fallen include u.s marines a navy
sailor and a soldier
in one of sergeant nicole g's last
instagram post the 23 year old shared a
photo of herself holding an afghan baby
with the caption i love my job something
she just told her sister so the last
things that she said was
i love being here this is amazing work
she couldn't wait to tell me more about
it after deployment 31 year old staff
sergeant darren hoover's father said his
son was devoted to family and to leading
fellow marines
and they would have followed him through
the gates of hell if that's what it took
and ultimately that's pretty much what
he did
twenty-year-old lance corporal kareem
nikoi's mother wrote on social media i
felt my soul leave my body as i was
screaming that it can't be true no
mother no parent should ever have to
hear that their child is gone
twenty-year-old lance corporal riley
mccallum will never get to experience
fatherhood his wife is expecting their
first child the servicemen and women
range in age from 20 to 31
all killed doing what they loved
18 us troops were also injured in that
attack at the kabul airport and right
now they are recovering in germany where
they were transported for medical care
tony wija thank you very much you know
the fact that they signed up for this
that they were doing something important
that they were saving lives does not
make it any easier for these families
not at all i was struck by what we just
said i noticed that too the ages they
were all so young to see that only one
of them was over the age of 30 as their
life was really just beginning yeah
sacrifices we aren't expecting at the
end of this war but exactly many of them
just 20 years old babies in their
parents arms yes